face à la crise en europe de l'est joe
biden monte encore d'un ton et s'adresse
directement à ses ressortissants basé en
ukraine
voilà ce que je demande les citoyens
américains présents là bas je devrais
partir maintenant en face il y avait une
des armées les plus puissantes au monde
les événements pourraient très vite
s'emballer
pas question pour autant d'envoyer des
soldats américains pour organiser une
éventuelle opération d'évacuation
précise le président américain aux
portes de l'otan la tension est toujours
aussi forte en biélorussie l'armée russe
poursuit ses exercices militaires prévus
jusqu'au 20 février un déploiement
jamais vu dans le pays depuis la fin de
la guerre froide pour le cren il s'agit
d'une provocation supplémentaire à
quelques kilomètres seulement de ses
frontières pour l'heure la voie
diplomatique reste privilégiée par
toutes les parties à berlin les
représentants russes ukrainiens
allemands et français ont longuement
discuté pour tenter d'avancer sur la
question du donbass cette région
séparatiste à l'est de l'ukraine en
proie à la guerre civile depuis 2000 14
ou 15 points d'accord n'a pu être
retrouvée après neuf heures de
discussions
évidemment il aurait été préférable
qu'on arrive à s'accorder sur quelque
chose il y a une volonté d'aller de
l'avant mais pour l'instant ça ne donne
rien
officiellement russes et ukrainiens
continue d'appeler au cessez-le-feu dans
le donbass mais sur le terrain les
tensions restent vives